[Music]
I'm leaving that 13 wins because I recognize your abilities
tan tan
The villainous jailbreak specialist who has succeeded in all prisons and jailbreaks around the world
11-25
No. 15 And
why they don't try to jail like other prisons
Listen again
No problem while I was away
No problem at all
I wonder if it's going to start getting
Dalai liar if it's a lie  When I hear it, I'll go to all the shoes
Monkey
I'll push their materials at a later date
8 days low
I'm sorry I'm
sorry Iwamatsu You said
they were villainous
Luna's fetal movement against the prison city and town
Bach
overseas business trip 13 companies
trembling with anger
13 Chief surveillance Fuchu
Very beginning
[Music]
ng
Ah ah ah
I thought I'd pull Kakuda's scam.
I don't want to draw my mother's
rice.
[Music]
ana
e to me
me
[Music]
nan
I was happy, but
I prepared to eat here
[Music]
4th
13th, it
's a prison, 69th
, fix the exe 25th
Yeah,
why did you go out to the 5th place
? I just reported to Mayor Kan that there was no problem, but
tan
Teruhide has a pant, so it's
Shikada.
Uno's music is proportional to
his teeth. The catcher is laughing and can't sleep as a volunteer.
That's why I slept on the night shift bear.
That's the quietest place.
Last night's night shift was Yamato, the deputy chief.
I will report that I was training from midnight to early morning.
People were doing Senna
.
That's all. I'm saying something extra.
Ahhhhhhh, I can choose
by carla.
The music here is so addictive compared to other prisons
Is it
okay? 8 Do you do your best?
Especially if you know the best of today's food, this technique is a wallet. It's
still a stupid guy.
The office is back.
9 I fell in love with the taste of my father. Yeah, yeah, I
was so confident, but I'm so happy.
I got it from that guy, but I'm refreshing and playing with it like
this Oh this is
how it's done And I'm going to match
the colors of all the noodles
like this
I'm two people in this difficult land  It's finally a match. Horror. It's funny if it's a guitar. It's
working. This time it's
ca Noah. It's hard to remove. Yeah
the
Sugane.  The reason why I
unlocked the wrong thing is that I'm talented in Hello.
Why is it good in a city that is useful for something different
?
]
Today, 13 companies are also working at a higher level. It's not easy to make a
nest with letters that each person said.
Don't say that. It's an
unexpectedly easy task. They're not easy. They
just fold and scrape.  It's a pretty difficult task from the bar.
You can't do it. The
furniture and the guests made here have a good reputation for being sweeter than the craftsmen there.
Especially wood carving is the key to woodworking.
That one person's minions are dexterous, so
show me which one, the charmer degree is already
dissed. Super space sky is activated.
It
's pretty good for you guys It's rare and decent I
made most of it, but Parker
I think I made a device with some ingenuity, but it's
mainly a drawer  How do you do it?
Training is good.
Is it okay? I
'm guessing why,
but I'm surprised that those guys are on the top
.  After all, if it's bald, we're flirting, isn't it?
It's a
[ __ ] guy.
Why is it until the day
?  Hey,
I don't hear if he's jailed for 13 minutes
[Music]
dark
I'm a prisoner who thinks about my position for a while.
It's okay if it's bald, I'm thinking it's someone else's affair I'm jailbreaking myself, so
I don't have to take responsibility at the beginning
Get
on, get on 9 Don't get
caught
[Music] Get
[Music]
Where are you going
to adjust the
zodiac?  Thank you for boarding.
Soon, the person in
front
of the car is in the middle
[Music]
Mayor Kan
This is convenient for those who need it
[Music]
Era is attached
f 2
Excuse me.
I'm going to ask 50 questions from now on.
Question 50
Please enter Iguro Clear for the food
you don't like.
Did
you do something? It's different from your 13 companies. You didn't do something. First of all, you're
still in the appreciation visit.
Wait,
your skin is still clean.
Also course training,
you
should buy it if it's
Sasheroro-I want you to make a mistake in the large-I
feel it from the thick ella that is close to the
previous one. It seems better to go through the stomach
.
Fortune-telling Chassman
Fashion
I brought the materials of the four prisoners of the 13 sticks I talked about the
other day.  In addition to the rude treatment of the music, I will drop the materials to be handed over to the
chairman and show them to the chairman.  I'm trying to get rid of my claim, I'm afraid I'm afraid I
'm sorry I feel sorry for the
resumption I wanted, then the
boom people are jailbreaking the distance rails It
seems like they're dead
now  The behavior is as described in the material
. No 4th place
except for the jailbreak history. Why
don't you oblige me for the time being
?  I don't take any action here-it
seems to say that it's comfortable.
This document doesn't describe the purpose and means of their jailbreak-
I'll explain that
at the beginning a.  It's
a little difficult to write as a document, but
what kind of content is it?
First of all, prisoner number 25
Nationality When
I was a drug buyer in the American slam street, I was arrested and protected.
My brother was light because he was there, but when he was
tested for drug effects, he
was found to have food allergies and road illnesses and was admitted to a medical juvenile training school.
While undergoing an examination at the Medical Reform School, 250,000
woke up to the power that was there at a stall that did
not depend on something, and was dehydrated as a book
.
It seems that even if he was imprisoned, he broke through the prison and jailbroken when the treatment day approached.
That's why I'm looking forward to the most of my time.
That's why I'm not trying to jailbreak now. It's
certainly difficult to write.
Next, prisoner number 69.
The ferocious fish and the guys who are housed in the prison are also
jailbreaking for a clear reason.
It seems that he had been jailbreaking because the business card of the juvenile training school where he was housed was bad
.
Non-continue
I'll ask you for the time being. In
tee
, prisoner number 11
Nationality was
arrested when he was daily to the back casino in England. He was taken to the jailbreak jailbreak.
I'm paying attention to each other
's bets, but that's what I'm talking about, but
it's different because I wanted to gamble and escaped.
In fact, I had to pass it through him in order to earn the demand period of my lover who was living in a wheelchair due to an accident,
so I was in charge of it.
It seems that he escaped from jailbreak. Even if
he entered this prison, he escaped on the day of the date
.
Finally, prisoner number 15 Han
Japanese national was arrested on suspicion of theft for 2 weeks at the juvenile training school
, but I think it was the day of the jailbreak week on that day.
You can say it's a prisoner who came
[Music]
What's the purpose of his jailbreak? It's
just a hobby.
I don't feel the consciousness of going out to him
now. [Music] I think it's safe for now
.
Thank you for believing in your words that there is nothing wrong with the current situation.
Honestly, I have doubts about his behavior.
I haven't looked it up, maybe I'm suspicious of the one I'm the most, so don't be
distracted at all
Tag You shouldn't jailbreak many times a day
.  It's not the time until it changes. I don't
think it's comfortable here
. I think it's a good place.
There is something like
me
san
[music]
Yoshi-kun on nov
ah ah ah
mar
[music] I
'm sorry to prepare a net jailbreak and it will be exciting I had a part here
If you think it's 8 heads, it's a minute, so if you decide to stop it, it's probably a movie in the opposition party
. It's an
impregnable fortress. Absolutely na na na
Just nani
t and
ni
[  Music]
Yeah Yeah Yeah rar rar [Music] [Applause] hal [Music]
toranoana 13 A new prisoner is coming to the staff of the company.
5 Black 8 venues Desperate Grump
Always
ana
me